[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hmm that's a damn good slurp yeah
oh man my headphones are really loud
right now compared to the uh down there
but
i turned them up tonight i'm really glad
to be with you guys on a slow news day
otherwise known as uh former vice
president joe biden is in office
so they follow his level of energy and
uh
uh
tim tulman you might need to do some in
my head i'm getting like this weird like
i'm talking through tin
cans here really uh we have quarter
black here today we have
gerald morgan a and dave landau one of
your favorites back in studio how are
you sir ahoy
i wouldn't say that why wouldn't i right
away you're just out of where it's black
history month and right
out of the chute you're out of touch uh
ahoy is not a
street i don't yeah right next to
malcolm x and martin luther king
you take a left on ahoy
no doubt here we go
[Music]
to get two today um you know uh dominion
is suing mike lindell so we're gonna
talk about that
we'll talk about the minimum wage and
why it actually hurts workers and of
course a lot some of the media is not
really telling you
77 decrease in covid in the last six
weeks what but you're going to wear a
mask to uh 2022.
dang it okay nice none of that changes
in any way shape or form uh but first of
course we want to honor our colored uh
brethren
um it's uh black history month
yeah um shoot us uh some information
here quarterback garrett some we want to
educate our audience yeah we want to
educate edumacatum all right so
uh oh boy little known fact ray charles
can actually see shapes at his right eye
really yeah it's fact true well i don't
know what to do well i don't know the
difference between legally well
here's a true story you know i told the
story before did i ever tell you my
my mother-in-law was like a singer who
toured with joni mitchell stevie nicks
aretha franklin
and so uh sometimes they would be around
musicians and my father-in-law one time
sat down
with ray charles he was reading a
playboy in braille
at the airport really really i hand hand
crossed my heart and hope to die
that guy could do everything blind porn
heroine piano
it's amazing and obviously he's a triple
threat obviously we braille one-handed
wow that is incredible was it just two
pieces
don't bother me don't bother me i'm
reading about them i'm busy i'm busy
just nipple braille it is on my mind um
was it just a pop-up i was about to say
yeah like a topographical map
right away look we talked rachel and i
spilled
right here this is a terrible start uh
so dominion is suing mike lindell
okay we have a lot to get to but this is
just breaking right now
um yeah i'm curious to see what happens
here yeah
because he said that would so make my
day because they would have to go into
discovery
and that would make my job a lot easier
that's what he said before and look
here's the thing
you know we we were um going to have
mike lindell on the show and people have
asked me why don't you focus on dominion
here's the thing youtube is um
really draconian i guess i would say
with their policies
and uh i can say that there's voter
fraud and i can say there's been but i
can't say that it affected the outcome
of the election everything that i've
said on this show
i can confirm because i've gone through
voter rolls myself so when i tell you
that's an address that doesn't exist
one of my interns has been there if not
me right exactly i'm allowed to make
those claims because i can
i can claim it under penalty of perjury
what do i think about dominion
and i don't have access to those
machines i would love
to because they made some very very
specific claims there
right right right addresses how people
internet through um whether they broke
into the firewall or false certification
if you didn't watch the
two-hour seemed like a parody
documentary
it still had some information in there
that really raised my eyebrows
if i could have access to those machines
that would be um
game changing and i guess it'll i'm it
maybe
we'll see we'll see i think i think he's
right though i think he they do open
themselves up quite a bit if they end up
surrounding somebody and i don't think
i mean it's going to be hard to make a
case could is there a reason for
somebody to believe that maybe something
shady went on
well i think when the shamwow guy uh
proved that al gore won
if you think yeah yeah that's true yeah
hey we have a but wait we have a quick
uh breaking news update oh no
i'm gonna wipe this up with my sleeve
while you're done where we got the
waterproof the supreme court has denied
trump's pennsylvania election challenge
as
moot oof oh well just now very surprised
that's not
as that's not the other one that was not
because the lawyer was mute
yeah i said i'm sorry i don't read lips
way to be a month late supreme court
like what if you're like oh no
it has some merits who are like well
then we've already got enough by the way
that's not the only guys like fire
yeah that's not the only case a lot of
people say well donald trump every
single case has been thrown out a lot of
cases have not
actually allowed any evidence to be
presented right and of the currently
active cases there's still there still
are plenty so we'll see what will happen
but you know listen
too little too late because i don't even
know if there's a system in place if
they do find something
new as well it's moot because they
waited two months yeah exactly that's
why
they're like hey guys we did our jobs
right now doing our jobs spy
yeah it's like someone's showing up late
for work yeah and they're like well you
know there's no work to do i guess this
is just go home like that's because you
showed up eight hours late it's fine
what do you want me to do not show up
eight hours late that would be
a little hard okay that's good a lot 15
minimum wage we're going to get to that
and here's the thing i want you to as we
move forward and i we
we pay our interns more than fifteen
dollars an hour okay but i don't want to
force other businesses to pay 15
an hour and i want you to think when you
order a filet of fish
and they forget the fish 15 15
an hour let's personalize it for you um
let's uh also something that we need to
talk about really quickly uh coca-cola
did you see this coca-cola they're uh
they're mandatory
employee training now and they're
mandatory video
what's impossible including a
recommendation on how to be less
white it said that yes yes yes which is
impossible i've been trying it
doesn't work very difficult very hard
which is crazy for a company that puts
vanilla in
everything and possibly i want to buy
the world of coke as the whitest
commercial
ever yeah because they're like well we
could start with water i went on vinyl
coke build a well
[Laughter]
uh they also got cosby to have a coke
and a smile
i for wait did cosby i think it was
cosby had a coke i thought he did pepsi
no did he i i know van halen did crystal
pepsi they were like we don't want
anything dark at all right yeah
so this is this is coca-cola just so but
people say it's beyond parody
i think we actually have a video from
linkedin a mandatory training video for
coca-cola because
this is these are the front lines of the
race war
and every moment that i spend in white
space i am being
deeply reinforced in the white world
view
oh why can't we all just be human beings
here why do we have to talk about race
i'm going to invalidate your experience
i'm a fish and i'm in water
and i'm moving with the current and
you're trying to take me out of the
water
and it's unbearable at first i thought i
was mis i thought that white space was
like a new social
media website yeah i thought it was the
room she was in that was just
white like i was like white myspace we
were just like popped collars
and hostess it looked like she was
wearing the jewel from titanic and i
also
wish she was at the bottom of the ocean
oh like the jewel
that was so that the end if for no other
reason titanic sucks because at the end
every she everything she goes through
and it's basically like the hope diamond
this isn't
she's like bye yeah she's like life is
the real treasure it's like yeah but
it'll be better with millions and
millions
of dollars you could also feed people
yeah i know this is an overused word but
it's not a binary choice
right you can still value life in
relationships and be
loaded just know your life
she made jack go to the bottom yeah yeah
killed him she was really quick too
titanic she's like i love you forever
yeah i'll never let go just like peels
them off like velcro like it's one of
those dark days you played as a kid
share the raft rose here's a good point
everything of value in her life she
throws in the ocean
she's got to be consistent oh rose you
[ __ ] ever heard of recycling so um
if you don't remember by the way this is
more pernicious than than you would
think or more inferior sorry i'm seeing
the stars again i keep seeing stars
in the studio because i'm here because
i'm looking at the lights
um this is the same woman who was on
jimmy kimmel this is the woman who is uh
deangelo was her name what's her first
name yeah
robin robin deangelo in case you've
forgotten here she isn't jimmy kimmel
i think white people should remove that
phrase from their vocabulary
i'm not racist it's not trust me
it's not convincing to black people
jimmy kimmel
well if you say so just imagine that
just saying that
and by the way i i i hate it when you
have these like when you actually
actually have racists who are like
what about white culture well here's the
problem when you just say white culture
it's not the same as african-american
culture because
you have you have jewish white americans
you have italians you have irish
you have whole characters you have
russians right but when you
say you are no longer allowed to defend
yourself because of your race
you're going to create racists white
people can no longer say i'm not racist
that'd be like saying to asians like you
can no longer say it i'm not cheap
but i'm not cheap but you can't say it
anymore right i'm just saying you're
just making a stereotype about an entire
race of people
and then you wonder why there's backlash
and this is they're talking about
removing it from your lexicon
uh i'm not racist just let's just remove
the defense and
something else too we actually have um
we obtained some exclusive footage
uh that for the training video that
didn't make the final cut
in this video i'm going to show you how
to quick walk step by step
now [ __ ] walk-in is a footwork style
created by the crips gang
it's the v step back
next i'm going to show you how to lift a
gran torino
i'm going to pop it in lock it here is
how to run
out of a red lobster
as if you did not pay the check and also
grab a tip off another table
don't leave empty-handed
by the way she just told white people
that they can't didn't she just that's
racism right that is just that an entire
race of people would behave a certain
way
yeah and what would you say hold on a
second d'angelo what you just said is
racist no it's not
oh you can't see how that works
could you imagine yet be less asian
you're just breaking chopsticks over
your knee
you can't have these you're not allowed
nobody knew this for you
she just said all white people do you
include everyone in there like would she
say this to oscar schindler
like you can't say that you did you
can't say that you're not a nazi
right really it's just these blanket
statements
uh speaking of which blanket statements
that are wildly offensive um
no one's paying attention to this and i
think i know why it's time for this week
in biden
oh yeah if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump and
you ain't black
and we have a second clip of this right
the slow okay you may have missed this
okay did you watch this clip yet i have
not
all right perfect gonna be surprised
hold on to your butts uh this was joe
biden in a recent test but just watch
the clip
look the range of challenges europe and
the united states must
take on together is broad and complex
and i'm either here i'm eager to hear
niggered here next what the oh he just
dropped an n-bomb yeah hold on a second
i know what you're gonna not a word
whisker but it's a bad whisker
here's we it's just a case for those who
missed it niggered here next
over here oh that's a word whipper
i didn't see that no one's seen it no
one's talked about it
oh boy that was at his virtual munich
security conference
see everyone here i told you they didn't
watch the clip that just
happened folks can you imagine if donald
trump yeah can you imagine if donald
trump had had that word whisker well he
was oh yeah
he oh yeah
that that hurt you quarter black carrot
i'm sorry i'm sorry sometimes it's a
comedy show you don't remember who you
hurt that's true
he has feelings too i'm sorry i we're
sorry that he's the former vice
president of the united states he didn't
even bother when i yelled at adam over
through my car window
well look 75 of you is fine okay yeah no
that's what keeps me together
all right this has been this weekend
button let's move on wait if you have a
problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black oh
okay you can follow me on instagram by
the way we're gonna miss really a heck
of a fluff for the president of the
united states
everyone here is just like oh my god
this is like ridiculous let me ask you
this okay here's my question of the day
we're going to talk about running
this minimum i don't care did you have
any of you seen that clip did you are
you sure you saw that clip
yeah i might have been are you sure
about that
and clip fact that you and you and you
and you and you
and you have not seen that clip is a
tragedy
in american journalism i don't think
he's racist right
i think he's an idiot and i think he's
going around the bend but let's just
let's be honest lou let's just let's
just hold people to a double standard
well and he also said the same around
yeah he also said it to the munich
conference to the german people
maybe he was thinking he was safe he's
like he's my people
like that's great let's build
[Laughter]
like come on there's so much comedy
there and if we repeat it we'll get
banned from youtube germany
no do you think do you think for a
second that this show would not be
immediately removed if any of us
accidentally said it yeah absolutely
accidentally
with an a not even the eo yeah yeah
exactly
you ain't black
so we're uh you can follow me on
instagram at live and by the way uh the
best way to um watch a show just monday
through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern just tune in that way
you don't have to rely on subscriptions
notifications
um and the best thing you can do if
you're watching right now is just
comment comment leave a comment that's
what helps us the most like it leave a
comment you can just comment whatever
you want i don't care let me know if you
saw this
joe biden clip now am i am i
exaggerating because i remember i was
describing i'm like did he or did he not
very clearly articulate the end result
mentally yes he did okay in the middle
of a sentence that didn't need any word
not even close yeah i don't even i don't
know what firing
you know thing happened i thought when i
watched it it was so obvious i'm like
this must be
fake yeah right because someone's and
then i no it's real and i thought why
well i don't i
i almost didn't want to be the first to
present it
because i thought i could be guilty by
association yeah yeah
he wasn't even rapping along to anything
he didn't even have wu-tang clan in the
scene anyway not even close
he's like turning down scarface rolling
up his
hey by the way you may not know this
here's some uh here's some silver lining
i guess
um about a silver's joe biden's glorious
plugs yeah
77 decrease in covet cases in six weeks
77 decrease that's good news
and uh there's some new reports that say
we may even have heard immunity by april
now let me be really clear on this
um this is not only 12 of the population
is vaccinated right right this was
starting over six weeks ago
this is what people have been saying for
a long time that we've sort of reached a
certain amount of herd immunity and
there's an article
in the wall street journal where someone
was talking about the tests and how they
underestimate cases and how many people
in the population have actually
likely been infected which by the way
means the mortality rate is lower but
we're at that point where
this clearly it's in the middle of
winter there aren't enough people
vaccinated at this point
it takes weeks for the vaccines to kick
in they were just talking about it on
cnn
and it's already decreasing so hope you
don't miss your business
right exactly and so they actually say
that this
gone by april this guy is not just some
random guy he's talked to a ton of
doctors i think whoever wrote this
article was a doctor as well
and he's saying literally gone by april
we should be vaccinating
only seniors not teachers that's what
matters they want to say that you're not
empathetic no no what we're saying at
this point
is that we need to vaccinate those who
are the most vulnerable i said this
right at the beginning and everyone said
you're crazy i said just just quarantine
old
people yeah and the compromise
and now they're saying everyone needs to
get a vaccine everyone needs to get both
doses before we move on
no just old people okay to people who
have compromised immune system
teachers because they're all a bunch of
voices and then
sorry no teachers sorry i meant heroes
right um so we have
reached somewhat hurt immunity this is
the only way you could
actually explain account for this this
decrease in cases
um but don't tell doctor about you that
do you think americans will still be
wearing masks for example in 2022
you know i think it is possible that
that's the case and again
it really depends on what you mean by
normality
exactly the way
i wish i loved anything as much as that
guy loves being on camera
and speaking which by the way what about
when the cameras aren't rolling dr fauci
what a germ oh geez what a germ
it's just look at that there's a guy
right now he's just going back he pulled
his gut out did you see that on top
that's like him coming home everything
is unhealthy with him
that's like you know a cop comes home
puts his gun in the fridge he comes and
pulls his mask down and
[Laughter]
those tangs are hanging on for dear life
it's not that he's a hypocrite it's that
he doesn't believe it's as scary as he
tries to tell you that's the issue
everyone's a hypocrite
i understand that it's that nancy pelosi
doesn't really think this is like ebola
with a 50
mortality it's that fouchy doesn't
really believe you need to wear a double
mask because he takes it off the second
the webcam stops
he also will be off camera the second it
stops that's why he keeps just breaking
numbers of masks going up and down he's
like yeah you gotta wear one how about
four
how about two no maybe twenty twenty two
maybe twenty twenty three
what's normal right i don't know i i
like doing this
[Laughter]
well they were they were talking about
this and said they said the overall
population mortality right now what is
it 0.15
i think is what this is talking about i
think what you meant to say was
the number that those doctors were
banned from facebook and youtube for
saying it likely was months ago that
number yeah
that number you will never get their
page back who will never get their
youtube channel back right those doctors
who were banned who actually saw
thousands of patients i'm like dr
voucher hasn't seen one in 30 years
yeah that number oh and by the way you
know all the people that have told us
that even if you get coveted you could
get it again the reinfection rate is
less than one percent with mild to no
symptoms and by the way
they did a 90 year old person who was a
survivor of the spanish flu
still had the ability to produce a fight
against spanish flu still had those
cells in his body
i think we're going to be fine and that
guy is one hell of a racist
he really is he's not he has to go
through the training course
he just said the n word yes no no no no
and the problem with the spaniards is
sometimes you can't see
you can't recognize them by sight some
of them are white
they have blonde hair they're trickery
have you ever seen a gladiator
you think it's like the mexicans but
they're not some of them have red hair
thank god i have anybodies it's like
prince harry
only he's spanish ginger spanish
ginger spanish it works oh by the way
hit the notification bell
uh if you are subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
youtube um
and this will just let you know but
again we're you know monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern is when you're
uh
when you're watching us here all right
let's get to the 15 but really quickly
let me go to cnn
they're uh confirming merrick garland
for attorney general look i'm confirmed
that would address
uh that's enough of that let me just
tell you something not a fan
but game has to respect game that's one
for you joe biden that's one
all right we're there like all right you
don't want to come for a room now we're
gonna okay
all right all right there you go okay
fine um
let's go back to here's one that's not
let's go to the minimum wage this is
something that this well first let's
start with this covet relief bill
everyone thinks well of course you want
the coveted relief bill why wouldn't you
want to give people money
well okay economics but we'll get to
that after um
there are there are possibly more
reasons to oppose the coveted relief
bill
than to support it yeah um and i'll get
to the primary gripe that i have with it
but let me give you a couple first off
this coveted relief bill which is meant
to help people during
coronavirus or had their businesses shut
down i don't know how this helps them
but
uh expansions to obamacare 128.5 billion
to teachers unions 40 billion to
universities 91 million to domestic and
international student loan borrowers
10 million to the preservation of native
american languages
i'm sorry that's just sort of like uh
like uh speaking through
the windex inhaling yeah is this us
apologizing for smallpox
10 million for that is it smoke signals
haven't you seen wind talkers come on
pretty cheap but what's also in this
bill which likely won't necessarily make
it all the way through
and is probably the most could could be
the most damaging thing to
to thrust upon the american public and
certainly small businesses
that i can think of well not the most
damage like a 20
minimum wage would be bad but 15 is bad
enough um is the 15
minimum wage would have devastating
consequences and of course this is
something that has been supported
by everyone on the left my radical idea
is that in america if somebody works 40
hours a week that person should not live
in poverty all right that's the radical
idea
i believe we should raise the minimum
wage to a living wage
and that is 15 bucks an hour over the
next several years
any job that is two dollars and 13
cents an hour is not a job it's
indentured
services we don't have those jobs i love
how she's saying that well she has
someone who
could come from a country that has
indentured servitude right next door
do you have to get tips
i did the french fries and i did the ice
cream
but the real two things at mcdonald's
yes is that
a majority of the folks who are working
there today
are relying on that income to sustain a
household and a family
i worked at mcdonald's as i put on the
black voice right now
i did the i did the ice cream i banged
the shift manager
yeah it was 1958 i was listening to big
ponds smoking some rock
oh my gosh they just they try to tug at
your heartstrings yeah aoc said two
dollars and 13 cents an hour guess what
buy law if you don't make enough tips to
get you to the minimum wage they have to
bump your pay up
aoc i know and you're lying hack and
they never have to do it because people
makes it yeah we're going to get in the
numbers here but
here's the thing this is something they
try and sell you and i want to tell you
something
it is the exact opposite of the truth
let me give you a summary
really quickly and you guys can tell me
people out there who are watching if
you're small business owners what do i
do to your business
they want you to think that a 15 minimum
wage is something that these giant
businesses can afford and they're the
only ones who oppose it no
look 15 minimum wage would would crush
absolutely destroy small businesses the
only people who actually support it are
the wealthy billionaires who earned
over a trillion dollars in net worth and
earnings in this pandemic
uh well i'll get into that in in more
detail but this is their talking point
here is aoc saying we need a 15
minimum wage because people like jeff
bezos otherwise well just the rich
friends will keep all the money their
self
do you think that's why he's a
billionaire because he pays his workers
starvation wages
and i think it's certainly a part of the
equation when you have a very large
workforce
and you underpay every single person
yeah
but when you underpay every single
person like the 25 000 jobs
she rejected from her municipality that
paid an average of wait
150 000 each how are you supposed to
live on that
that's like what a congress person gets
paid poverty but it's like what it's
like when i get paid but if you couldn't
do all the insider trading because for
them it's illegal
[Laughter]
she didn't leave herself any wiggle room
at all every single person has paid
starvation wages
everything even the coo is starvation
wages i'm sorry millions of dollars
later instead we just shut down all the
neighborhoods and no one made anything
yeah it's great we have no money to
spend on helping people
have you been to jamaica queens lately
it's awful
which is what i call no gentrification
so let's
chalk that up as a win also i did use
the word equation earlier i'm not
entirely sure wouldn't know what it
means but
you know i saw a guy in an eight ball
jacket stab another guy who was wearing
an eight ball
jacket and i said thank god we don't
have those 25
000 jobs because we would lose we would
lose who we
are who are we if not being stabbed in
eight ball jackets
um here's the thing the 15 minimum wage
is almost exclusively
and this is like you see with with
amazon supported by the biggest
companies in the world
you look at the most powerful companies
right these super corporations
why because it's a way to put smaller
companies out of business
a perfect example when this is just how
government screws things up you know
rent forgiveness i don't know if you saw
this in georgia rent forgiveness well
what does that mean well you just don't
pay rent
really yeah it worked it just means that
you want don't want to pay rent don't
pay rent well guess what you can't find
right now in georgia
you can no longer find cheap housing
because
people who own these leasing apartments
they won't lease them out because it's
one thing
to have you know burning a hole in your
pocket if you keep it empty this
apartment it's another thing to have an
inferno in your pocket because people
are using the utilities and damaging
your property
those are the unintended consequences
think about covet i remember landing in
michigan
and they said oh you can't go to any
stores everything is shut down really
aside from the weed shops in costco
so why can't go to a farmer's market i
can't go to a local mom-and-pop store
but costco and walmart are still open
and home depot still open well you
wonder why they support a minimum wage
and the mom and pop store can't afford
it just like big banks support the
bailouts think about that for a second
too big to fail why because there is no
local bank that can come up and compete
with them if they have a never-ending
supply of federal funding
this is the issue the democrats and this
is why you see right now this this
changing the demographics that the
republican party
is the party of the working class sort
of a blue collar party yeah
they always line up with big powerful
corporations whether it's big tech for
censorship
whether it's big corporations for a
minimum wage just look at the small
business
all of the associations in america small
to mid-sized businesses they all oppose
it
amazon google those places targets
support it yeah absolutely they can they
could just drive the competition out but
let
not all jobs are worth 15 dollars an
hour right we talked about that just
briefly a second ago but think about the
jobs
i need to talk with you after the show
come on
i want to be an intern push me up to an
intern
look we talked about it just a minute
ago but restaurants are
disproportionately hurt by this because
now instead of having to bump you up to
whatever it was eight or ten bucks an
hour if you're like the worst server in
the world and can't get enough tips over
the course of an hour
now they have to bump you to 15. guess
what they're gonna do they're just not
gonna have as many people they're gonna
be like screw we can't come back we've
already been hit
by this in texas they were hit by the
ice storm on valentine's day they were
counting on that money to come in for
people wanting to go
out now they're trying to reopen and
they've got this staring them in the
face
this is exclusively supported by the
billionaires who they increased
their earnings by one trillion dollars
in six months under the pandemic
contrast that
sixty percent of businesses may be
permanently closed
by december do people not paying rent in
georgia have anything to do with the
fact that coca-cola is there
i you know what i'm not entirely sure
okay i just want to they just need to be
less
white if they are they do you know
that's the good thinking
i see i explain jokes sometimes as well
as step on them
and here's what they but here's the
thing this is when sometimes they tip
their hand when you know a journalist
goes rogue and my god actually asks them
a question um
where right now you have this man who
basically says well you know what then
if these small businesses can't afford a
15
then we don't want they shouldn't exist
he says it well of course large
businesses like amazon
uh and mcdonald's for example can can
and perhaps should pay more but i'm
wondering what is your
plan for smaller businesses how does
this in your view affect
mom and pop businesses who are just
struggling to keep their doors open keep
workers on the payroll right now
well they shouldn't be doing it by
paying people low wages we don't want
uh low-wage businesses i think most
successful small businesses can pay
a fair wage so i love small businesses
i'm all for it but i don't want small
businesses that are underpaying
employees by the way it should be noted
it's easy to say when you've never
worked for a business
yes yeah exactly would you ever sign
that this is the danger with these
people
joe biden has spent 48 years in
government
aoc went to college part-time bartender
and now she's in charge of your economic
decisions
she's never not suckled at the taxpayers
to eat
right that's the danger think of the i
want you to think of the people in
college
who are part of the anarcho-socialist
club right people who they loved
dabbling in economic theory and they
never worked a real job
now put them in charge of your business
that's what this bill is
yeah and then they they call it a fair
wage right well okay let me let me just
explain to you how this works
i have a job that i need done what's
fair is me saying hey i think it's worth
this much you're going to add this much
production to the value of whatever
product or service that i'm putting out
there
i get to tell you and you have the
choice of saying yes or no guess what if
you don't like the wage that your skills
currently will earn you
go get more skills that's the motivation
for you it's like giving a trophy to
everybody there's no motivation to
perform better
you get a trophy anyway that same guy
right there i forgot his name that
representative um he said uh
well really if we look if we adjust for
inflation like after the great
depression and wage increases right now
the minimum wage should be 23. because
that's a that's in direct relation to
their value contributed
that's what again you think of just when
you go and order
i don't know uh a quarter pounder with
cheese only it's a nothing pounder with
cheese this has happened to me at the
drive-thru
and 23 an hour i forgot to live to
deliver pizzas because i was high
did you get tipped though no i just i
came back and i was like oh yeah i knew
i had to do something
the whole purpose for you leaving was to
do it oh yeah seriously
yeah there's no way i mean when you're
at that position you don't have a skill
set that's why you're not making 15
dollars but for some reason
they only think of the consequence of
the guy who deserves 23 an hour 15 an
hour who's high delivering pizzas they
don't think of that business owner
let's go through this scenario okay if
you lived in a liberal states
state where all of their policies that
they wanted in a dreamland which they're
kind of there
uh they could enact okay so you're high
and you don't deliver the pizzas but the
guy still has to pay 23 an hour because
that's the minimum wage and he can't
fire you because of workers rights and
you can't have a no fault state for
firing so this person is going to
continue being employed but maybe they
spend their money on drugs and they
don't actually pay their rent but they
go home and they have squatters rights
and you can't actually
evict someone from rent we've all seen
pacific heights so you can't kick them
out of the apartment you end up with a
matthew modine
kevin uh michael keaton's scenario with
the guy putting roaches in your
apartment so he's not contributing to
his job
he's not contributing to rent we've hurt
the business owner and we've hurt the
landlord but screw him no rent and let's
pay someone this much regardless of
performance there you go
there's america there's your american
dream we used to think it was work hard
get ahead white picket fence have a wife
some children but now we know that that
destroys the environment
now it's do nothing and get more than
the guy who risked everything to create
a business
you're america yeah well where do they
think the money's going to come from
they don't that's rich problem
yeah it's always rich people they always
have all the money these rich people
yeah it's like look it's going to be 16
for your big mac and you're like as long
as they're getting money right
yeah no i'm just pissed at that it's a
little crappy burger
as long as i know that those people who
slap their clientele
at the midnight or two in the morning
world star hip-hop videos are getting 22
an hour
i feel good about patronizing the waffle
house well you know what mcdonald's did
is they just went to these
self-service kiosks so like we're
putting robots they're not worth that
much money
in new york they have atm machines and
it's just like homeless people licking
them and you're like i'll pass
i mean just think does anyone when was
the last time you saw a bag boy
yeah think about it we just demanded
that we increase wages and now
you've given yourself a job at the
grocery store
you have to do your own checkout exactly
that's true the only bad boy is just
running cash for cartels
it pays more than fifteen dollars an
hour and it's worth every penny and they
really just use him as a bag it's just
more it's just
more uh it's less offensive than mule
yeah and by the way i don't know how
this gets so
squeezed into a coveted relief bill
right so this is supposed to help people
that have been hurt
yeah well the congressional budget
office said that it'll cost 1.4 million
jobs
yeah so there you go that'll help those
people so that's just the that's just
what can actually be quantified not to
mention again the 60
of businesses that were open in april
will be closed by september unbelievable
but amazon won't be affected by it and
here's the thing
if only we had some specific examples
and i always like to go back to some of
these we'll get to denmark in a little
bit
just because i love that the prime
minister told bernie to shut the hell up
but let's go through you know american
samoa is one of them and we've all seen
those people
terrifying they're like they have more
pop
per capita nfl players yeah than
anywhere else in the world
they're true insanely strong very true
um so you would think in other words
they could be industrious
well no uh i saw moana that's a horrible
film yes
it's dwayne the rock i don't mind dwayne
by the way
never touch steroids that's what he said
he touched the munch in college and they
terrified him so he never so that his
veins are all natural his
veins in his lower stomach and forehead
grows naturally at 48.
a young rock that's new this week people
watch it
uh american samoa they were devastated
by a minimum wage right they had tuna
canneries which was that was their main
they had
two major tuning tuna canneries i
believe and they were sent to georgia
right and there was a reason there was a
recent four dollar wage like a four
dollar wage hike
in long beach and what happened was just
uh kroger just decided to close their
stores says well we can't we just closed
your store yeah
wow so all the krogers in long beach
gone that's insane right we have these
real world examples we have these little
microcosms like they happen in
california or american small and they
haven't bounced back
uh by the way this is something else
that people don't necessarily take into
account so
they were skilled jobs in new york we
were talking about amazon right yes 20
something thousand jobs at well over six
figures
average by the way billions of dollars
in tax revenue yeah unbelievable
but that wasn't enough so that's how you
know she doesn't really care about the
minimum wage she didn't want jobs that
were paying six figures for crying out
loud but
amazon has openly supported a 15 minimum
wage and they pay a 15
minimum wage but as they virtue signal
about that they actually just eliminated
workhouse productivity and stock options
for their lowest skilled workers so
it actually resulted in a net loss of
income
for many of their employees hey do you
know who don't have stock options and in
productivity options uh small businesses
oh so amazon says well yeah sure we can
pay 15
an hour they decrease all of these
options all of these benefits
and the worker is left holding the bag
man well look if somebody is going to
end up paying the company
they're going to cut benefits sackman
that's better that way
they're either going to cut benefits
they're going to cut jobs they're going
to bring in automation they're going to
do all of these things and bernie
sanders and aoc if they
really are trying to help people out
instead of this whole fight for 15
campaign how about earn 15. that would
help more people out there than you
trying to change the minimum wage
in five years by the way when it would
fully just love for once like you were
talking about how you
forgot to deliver pizzas because you
were real very altered
honest moments i just wish because
bernie sanders and and and
kamala harris who did the i did the
burgers i did the ice cream
i worked at mcdowell's
i was selling the mc whoppers
prince long john what i don't know
louis anderson
um what was this what was i saying
before this what was that i have no idea
no it was about uh uh you know automated
machines coming into mcdowell
no that's what i was saying no that's
not what i was talking about anyway guys
remember you can comment below just
comment comment comment that's the best
thing you can do you can let me know
what it was that i was talking about
but it really it it's one of those oh
this is what i was talking about i just
wish you were you were high that's right
you said you have permanent brain damage
from all those years that's correct
hppd from acid oh it's just he but he's
lovable
ahoy so
[Laughter]
um so what i would just love is when you
have these folks who
who say like well you know i believe
that everyone not everyone and can we
also just acknowledge that that's not
really an
outlier there are it's not just a few
there's a huge percentage of the
american workforce
who would rather get higher who would
rather not be productive collect their
check they don't care
what that business does they don't care
if that place stays in business
a lot of people don't care about their
jobs and don't care about contributing
they just want to clock in and clock
that's just the reality i just wish that
they acknowledged it
but they act as though every employee
this is what marxism is based on
everyone has ownership of their space
and every employee should
own a piece of that company well the
truth is it's not the reality and
they're not outliers a huge percentage
of this workforce does not give a rat's
ass
and should be paid accordingly they
should be paid
not give a rat's ass wages yeah
absolutely i get nervous when i
ask somebody for something at a store
when they're an employee yes they just
get
mad at you i know like ah you know you
need
a raise we need more of you in this
store
i like your attitude i like how you're
on the phone
and mad at me for shopping here
yeah i love how you're clipping your
nails in the deli section
is that a 23 20 24 an hour you did you
made it to
good amazing supervisor good for you
could you just get that hang nail off
there yeah thanks i'll take my turkey
pastrami and be on my way
um get an insulin discount here because
boy are you big
it's like you do nothing all day yeah
losing some weight would might help that
but how much is the foot weight because
that's probably not going to be there
long mate just put you under the wire
good for you somebody's going to drop 30
pounds
[Laughter]
and this is something else that they use
as an example they try to point to
successful examples but it's a lie they
constantly point to
what else a scandinavian country denmark
and i think we should look to countries
like denmark
like sweden and norway and learn from
what they have accomplished
for their working people well denmark
doesn't have a minimum wage so
you're bad [ __ ] crazy and really stupid
look at that
they don't even have a minimum wage now
i know what you'll say they're actually
they don't have a minimum wage but
they're set by trade unions they're very
strong trade but fine you know what they
don't have a minimum wage so let's just
start with that
it's like it's in europe you know it's
uh like denmark
like denmark and sweden germany in the
40s whatever
you know it'll work out and despite
having no minimum wage it is true here
this is true credit where it's due they
have higher average hourly wages
than the united states but when you take
into account using the international
metric of purchasing power
they actually have 44 less than the
average american so a lot of people
don't realize this they talk about
denmark again let's go through this
no minimum wage strong trade unions even
though no minimum wage they have a
slightly higher average
average hourly wage but it accounts to
about 44
less than you have as an american with
purchasing power so let's look at what
the average person in denmark pays this
socialist utopia they pay quadruple what
americans pay
to buy apartments double what americans
pay for a basic
cheap used car and triple to double
often triple for any of these things i
created a list i think we have an
overlay basic groceries restaurants
clothing
basics too is necessities like milk eggs
transportation rent gym membership going
to the movies do you really think so
let's take that into account if we
follow that lead do you really think
that a 15
minimum wage is going to give americans
the ability to afford
a 12 year old 40 000 shitty car
and an 800 000 one bedroom apartment
because that's what you're looking at
with purchasing power when you do the
averages yeah
absolutely so the point it wouldn't fix
the problem no it wouldn't fix a problem
and you
you when you oversimplify this and say
well if they can do it we can do it it's
like saying well if they can provide
free healthcare well they don't pay for
a military okay
we pay for that for them there's a
reason why we have a better country
yeah exactly not to mention the i would
say it's not an
insignificant fact that the that it's a
very small homogenous country and they
don't have to compete with
millions in foreign undocumented
unskilled labor
that does play a role in wages and the
economy
well yeah well i feel like i've overpaid
for my apartment and car
yeah someone sent coke to denmark so
they learn how to not be so damn white
let's do that send them coke and the ice
cream hold on i gotta go blow another
guy i don't know it's just job security
give me some of that montel and here's
something that's funny too this is one
thing that has always really interested
me
and no one else ever talks about this
right they say that um
uh well the danes in the swedish they
have higher living standards in the
united states and that takes into
account a lot of things and again the
people who say this are
forty thousand dollars for a used old
jetta look it up that's actually a thing
okay wow so let's just say that even
including all that because of your
social safety nets in denmark and in
these scandinavian countries they do
have a higher living standard than
americans
well that is true according to whatever
international metric they use but here's
something they never tell you
danish americans so when you take those
stains and you transplant them in the
united states
they have a 55 percent higher living
standard than those living in denmark
swedish americans have a 53 percent
higher standard of living
than swedish swedes in sweden so what
you do is you take people from these
countries that are incredibly
homogeneous that have
that have an unbelievably burdensome tax
system
and they also have a culture that
appreciates to some degree or another
and i know i'm surprised saying this
about sweden but denmark a lot of these
countries
that appreciates work that appreciates a
work ethic being industrious
you transplant them to the land of
opportunity and they do
far better we have all of these sources
of bill available at lighter
earthquaker.com
it's one of those factoids that people
don't believe because and i didn't
believe it when i first read it
yeah well and republicans basically are
saying in this bill look we can't govern
this way we can't just throw everything
into a relief package and say it's the
relief package it's almost 2 trillion
if 15 bernie sanders aoc joe biden is
such a great idea
put it on its own let's vote on just
that and they will never
ever do that they're scared because
nobody would support this not with any
of the facts
some people would support it no i mean
you know reasonable people young dave
landau would support it
oh yeah i made fifteen dollars an hour
really yeah i did stealing
no i was saying this is in detroit yeah
it's a pizza boy no
i was talking true it was 97 yeah and i
was
uh well no i was detailing cars for uh
you know so it doesn't count what can
you steal from the change dish oh the no
i've never made it okay take a penny
leave a penny yeah
no i know i didn't and i was very bad
take a 20 leave a dime yeah no this may
change that's just he forgot his wheat
um all right so can you let me know uh
what it is uh where you line up on on
on this issue with a 15 minimum wage and
i understand this again it comes down to
the idea that liberals are somehow
empathetic it's predicated and we're
empathetic we want everyone to make 15
but it's not practical you haven't
thought this through you haven't walked
through the entire sequence
if there's nothing else that changes
here with the perception
of conservatism i just want people to
understand that look we all want what's
best
the founding fathers wanted what was
best for americans that's why they left
right and they put these rules and
systems into place to be as
uh to be as the least intrusive they
possibly could be because they believe
that that would be the best way
for americans to pursue life liberty
happiness
so everyone cares right and this country
has created
more wealthy people than any other
country in the history of the world and
we have better class mobility than any
other country in the world we've pulled
more people out of poverty than any
other country in the world
doesn't mean we're perfect but i don't
necessarily know that we want to do it
like the danes
um let's move on to someone who i
actually really do like speaking of this
we just we spent too much time on people
who and by the way it's wrong to hate
guilty
i was almost not here i was almost not i
was almost hauled off for murder because
there was someone curling in the squat
rack
yeah i'm sorry about that that that
bothers me more than late-term abortion
it's so and it's not the severity of it
it's just i'm sorry
what it's not the severity it's the
commonality of it
where you just walk up this guy like
it's it's the only squatting rack and
the signal is
hey are just are you squatting in the
squat rack no no i'm curling like
oh how long that's the sign to get your
at to get your
shrunk and shriveled emaciated out of
the squat rack
[Laughter]
sometimes i quit quarrel
my doctor just looks at his watch and
goes it'll be soon
i don't even know exercise terms
how long do you think i shh how do you
feel about hey
how do you feel about my pillow have you
tried the my pillow is it a nice pillow
would you like a would you like a david
hogg good pillow
he just puts a gun
good pillow you stick your head in it
it's bulletproof yes yeah
please go let's test it out of course
we're talking about dave landau
not david hogg yeah just to be very very
clear and to be clear it was joe biden
who stuck the landing on the er
uh n word earlier not myself for the
youtube auto word recognition
yeah yeah not us i don't want the louder
with crowder transcript to read the word
that joe
biden said and be associated with me
with the former vice president of the
united states
peace be upon him um so governor
desantis
i'm really liking this guy yeah um and i
i don't think he's actually going to be
on the ticket
uh nationally because he seems to
actually want to do his job as as
governor
um but let's go through the the top
examples as to why i'm a big fan of
desantis first off
they did everything right with covet
yeah compared to new york absolutely
didn't lie about it
uh didn't lock down and uh they're doing
okay and it's amazing how many senior
citizens they have it's just a sea
of white hair yeah and then the sea i
thought florida was going to be
decimated i th just because of the
democratic people yeah i just thought
old people
it's going to go through there like
wildfire that's what i thought too but
imagine if all of the conservatives had
the balls
to talk to the media like this governor
what has gone wrong with the rollout of
the vaccine that we've seen
phone lines jammed websites crashed a
lot of demand i mean i think at the end
of the day
excuse me excuse me you just said what
has gone wrong so i'm answering the
question if i could complete the
question though so are you going to give
a speech are you going to answer
ask a question with all due respect you
asked the question i'm going to answer
it
you're not no you're you're giving a
speech you ask the question i am trying
to ask you
you're going to ask how many questions
you get three they only got one question
why do you get three
he's my aim i love to every time he
answers
he wins yeah exactly every single time
he's a you know what it is he's
he's a guy who realized sort of when
you're starting stand up and you realize
oh wait a second
i have the microphone and they don't
right and it's not really a fair fight
he's realized that he's like wait a
second i can continue and they have a
limited window so i'm going to embarrass
them
people say oh that's rude of him no it's
not she was trying to make a point
by asking the question in a certain way
to make him look better oh my god
all the time yeah yeah she wants a
gotcha moment they don't want to ask
that question they want to become a star
by writing this guy in his place it's
like when you have people at church and
they're praying but they're not praying
like and lord we thank you that gerald
learned to put the uh the monitoring
software on his computer that provides
an accountability
thank you so much that he has been clear
of his desire to tithe ten percent
right
please clear my browsing history
honey i have no issues with that at all
breathe more we need to fire dave lando
why
because he makes me because i see stars
when i don't want to laugh anymore
like can we just let's let's just clone
you and put you in his chair
[Laughter]
so desantis have you considered a bill
angle
show that'll cure you right up um
i love you he handles criticism way
better than a lot of republicans need to
be unapologetic that's what i do
appreciate about the census here he is
where they were trying again the media
to attack him in a partisan way
regarding his handling of the vaccine
rollouts to different municipalities
it's just like you said he always wins
but look i mean if manatee county
doesn't like us doing this
then we are totally fine with putting
this in counties that want it
and we're totally happy to do that so
anyone that's saying that
let us know if you want us to send to
sarasota next time
or charlotte or pasco or wherever uh
let us know we're happy to do it but i
think most people if we have an
opportunity to to bring vaccines and do
it efficiently
i think that they're gonna want it
[Laughter]
he gives them like a or b yeah it's like
with a kid like
well you know what timmy i can give your
if you don't eat your dinner i can give
your dessert to your brother and your
sister
and your other brother and not feed you
for days on it and lock you in a closet
but i think you probably want to finish
your vegetables
yes you read my mind i completely
uh zoned out after you said manatee
county
pictured lining up to get a vaccine
that's about right i think
wearing old lady wigs like those people
did in florida yeah i'm not a sea cow
i'm an old lady
two manatees on each other's shoulder
and a trench coat
hi hello sir
what's your name no well
you know what that's obesity is a
problem it is especially
sick named manatee
oh but they're getting paid 23 hours so
let's do this it's very helpful that's
good
they are an endangered species so that's
true
how are they i mean again god has picked
them for extinction
really i always whenever i see one i'm
in florida and i see a manatee i think
you're still around how they're in the
wild because when you think about it
right
sharks have been around through
prehistoric times this is the apex
predator
so the entire time the manatee manatee's
been around a shark has been around yeah
i'm like sharks why don't you just why
are you chasing seals why are you
chasing anything there's there do you
it's it's
it's just a giant log that's made of
food it's too
it's too easy i think there's no sport
in it they're like that's boring
haven't you seen how bad it is that is
essentially what we've
done with people yeah some were supposed
to go extinct and now we're just letting
them breed
we get the worst version we're like what
do we do with this we're like let's give
it 23 an hour it's a disaster
um sorry this is no i think it's
happening to a lot of people but it is
true many of you should be in danger
yeah no offense to most of you watching
none none so after twitter permanently
bantrum which by the way is still crazy
when you think about it enduro's still
on there you have hamas representatives
still on there
yeah he's gone can't get buried in
arlington
seems like a specific oh my gosh so
after trump gets banned from twitter uh
desantis did he introduces legislation
to limit and this is this is landmark
uh if you don't know what it is but he
introduces legislation to limit the
power of big tech within his parameters
as it relates to the state of florida
here he is explaining it so if a
technology company deplatforms a
candidate for elected office in florida
during an election a company will face a
daily fine of a hundred thousand dollars
until the candidates access to the
platform
is restored if i were to give something
of value to a candidate or political
committee it would be a contribution
but big tech has been manipulating news
content and designing algorithms
to give the upper hand to their
candidates of choice and they do so
scot-free
again euphemistically called content
moderation i think it's more
political manipulation the message is
loud and clear
when it comes to elections in florida
big tech should stay
out of it why is it so why would it be
so hard for people
for republicans on a national level to
do this that's what bothers me when you
think about it
and i can i can explain this now because
it turns out i can't do this legally
i checked with my lawyer what i want but
i don't live in florida what i wanted to
do
was run for some local office in florida
that was
won by like eight votes like constable
or dog catcher yeah and then
sue facebook for a hundred thousand
dollars president
and i also think donald trump should run
in some county for like city council but
he won by 92 percent
and just and then just tweet i'm back
can't stop won't stop i'm just telling
you if anyone else if i were able to do
it i would just run a national campaign
like you've had a problem manatee county
there's been no accountability for your
dog catchers well that ends today on
billboards
just so that there would be no chance of
an opponent getting the upper hand
unfortunately election laws say that
unless i'm hillary clinton and i have a
timeshare for two weeks i actually have
to live in florida
how fun would it be though to make
commercials for that against the other
man i hear he kills the dogs once they
get in the car
yeah tell us about your freezer
candidate x
[Laughter]
there are so many republican governors
out there that could just do this yeah
that this is this is all you have to do
is just a nod to big tech to say we're
watching
we understand what you're doing and you
have to stop and you know what this is
an example of something that i think
look i think they would eat
they would just eat the bill if it were
donald trump 100 000 a day
but they're not going to do it with
every single local city council
representative
that's something let's go all right
let's leave them on because think about
it for a second you should not be able
to censor someone running for office who
represents almost
half of the constituency yeah absolutely
i mean how many how many republican
governors are there right now i think
it's well over half i can't remember the
exact number but
if every one of them did that right now
big tech would have to
change they do they would have to they'd
be forced to let's just have another
hearing
okay uh he also import sound bites he
also introduced to bill uh desantis by
the way
on election security so we introduced
the big tech bill now kind of some
kind of some issues near and dear to my
uh compromised heart
yeah um just the outflow here's c and
stars
here's the uh here's the election uh
security bill
no mass mail-in voting no ballot
harvesting signature verification
meaningful observation of signature
matching no grants from third party
organizations
real-time reporting of voter turnout at
the precinct level and election
supervisors must report the number of
ballots requested
how many have been received and how many
are left to be counted
it's almost like without pointing it out
this is made to address
the last election it's almost like it
covers
all of the bases this is all very
reasonable by the way
yeah if you if you promoted this yeah
ten years ago if you just said hey these
are the rules like
fine go ahead and nobody's gonna oppose
that go for it it's it's remarkable
my wife my wife cannot call in to my
bank
to raise my credit card limit and i
don't even you it's just so that that
way it's better for your credit score
apparently yeah
my wife can't do it even though i've
authorized her 15
times but someone can fill out my down
ticket ballot without even my john
hancock so that uncle sam
is a little wise to what's going on i
just i just it's remarkable to me
unbelievable
yeah she started doing it once she heard
about your heart
think ahead that's true nice yeah
[Laughter]
oh um here's another one by the way uh
just another
just desantis i really wish this guy
would run i think he will i do i really
do
there's there's so much time between now
and when that's going to happen he
doesn't need to say a word about it now
right just keep doing what he's doing do
you think he's playing it koi like no
i don't know no i think i think every
politician that well not every there's
so many politicians
i would never do that i am too busy
doing the job for the people that i'm
sorry you want me to be president yes
yes
i would run for president in fact how
did you talk about it i mean
could you could you imagine this guy
debate well i mean
he wouldn't be debating by me probably
debating harris but let's just say in a
world could you imagine him
what do you get listen stop stop stop
stop
actuary tables so let's be honest
um could you imagine him debating though
joe biden it would be like all the
things you like about donald trump minus
the lack of discipline
right he won't get distracted yeah he'll
be like when biden has you know says the
n word
like do it what did you just dip it huh
did you just say that n word like he
would call him out
i just fart on stage no come on man
ahoy um so i would just love to see this
guy
who would you like to see most it's too
early and i don't i'm not in the
business of endorsing candidates funny
enough the person i probably agree mo
agree with most in politics is rand paul
i have no interest in seeing him run for
president yeah
i agreed yeah i think his hair i think
it's the hair
off the fattiness yeah well joe biden
said the n-word
international televised but not me
i wouldn't do that i would never do that
because i respect the american
constituency and i don't think that
seeing the n
word is something that most of them
appreciate like what
i don't want to be a pothead from
california that's pretty much what he's
saying
yes that's why i love it um which
which is which is the next clip that we
have
is it the final clip yes okay but first
before that he also said the florida by
the way that wouldn't mandate covid
vaccines
um which again i'm not against or masks
i'm not against vaccines
i'm against triple masking just because
it doesn't i just don't
just you know what cause screw you
that's why because i don't that's all
that's like i don't want to
anyone who says it doesn't i'm against
suffocation yes that's sort of where i
i lie i would just let's just see how
many people
would if we tell them that a hundred
percent effective in reducing
transmission is just as
it's just a a plastic bag with a zip tie
it would be a hundred percent it would
be high i mean it would be 100
if you need said mask pick it up from
dave's doctor
um but i've offered to pay for the
vaccine for anyone in this uh no one
wants it no
no let me go to the control room uh
control room by the way can
you um if you let him know that um i'll
pay for anyone in this office who wants
a covered vaccine yeah anyone who wants
one okay i don't want one
my doctor offered me the hank aaron
i'll take a different one please no no
no that one
my doctor offered me the air and
spelling i just came around oh geez yeah
what is this i look like a half moon um
is he dead
aaron's spelling yeah that's a she she
she is beverly hills 902
i know you're thinking of there's
someone who has a um no i don't know
oh yeah yeah yeah the dad was aaron
spelling spelling tori
that's ryan's the dad well then if he's
dead i'm sorry either way both should be
and now i feel like we've issued an
apology i was talking about tori
spelling clearly about the half moon
reference
she has a book called storytelling get
it
oh because tory's spelling it oh geez
all right
final clip that and we have to get going
pretty soon it's a mug club we're going
to be playing photoshopped or not and
taking your chat
live with credit.com but the final clip
here is uh like president donald trump
desantis is not a fan of fake news and
he's not afraid to call it out
the media is worried about that
obviously you guys really love that
you don't care as much if it's a quote
peaceful protest then it's fine
you don't care as much if they're
celebrating a bite in election
you only care about if it's people that
you don't like so i'm a bucks fan
i'm damn proud of what they did on
sunday night
and so in terms of the uk variant here's
what we know
we know based on all the the evidence
that these vaccines are going to be
effective against that
by the way i love it when there's a
press conference and there are people
also cheering him
yeah it just goes to show you how
different it is when someone actually
speaks
yeah the mind of what hap the opinion
that half a half of all america have
yeah and he's a little bit more
articulate too
right he doesn't fumble around with his
words yeah
i'm trying to be nice okay being nice
just saying donald trump if he said and
i
by the way obviously i like donald trump
but donald trump if you were saying that
he would say look
listen the news likes that okay but
really what we know about
the uk variant okay because everyone's
talking about the uk variant that's what
they're saying the uk married
the uk the united the variant from the
united
kingdom some people say britain it's not
just britain it's the uk
they have a very they have a south
african there's a there's a variant
folks
from brazil but we're not talking about
that right now
and what do we know okay what do we know
about the uk variant
listen no excuse me i'm talking stop the
uk
varian the vaccines are fantastic for
the uk variant it's what we know
they are so good and not the the uk
variant is
not so fantastic
but the vaccine is fantastic
and i'm really happy because we were so
worried about the youth
we were so worried about the united
kingdom you're like okay
all right i give i give i'm sorry i'll
never ask another question again sir but
he's just it's like donald trump with
the media though i think this part is
just constantly running out the clock
yeah that's really true oh i meant to
get to your question
oh so sorry
sorry tapper that's what i like about
desantos though he just shuts them down
very fast next person to be hurt by me
like a 90s next victim now who's next
yeah exactly uh all right well listen we
actually have to get going speaking
which we have some more to talk about
that
believe it or not cannot be discussed
here on youtube the best thing you can
do if you're watching
this has been our is just commenting
comment your thoughts on ron desantis 15
minimum wage and have you seen that clip
of joe biden saying the n word anywhere
just comment on that below comment
comment comment youtube
we don't we don't love you but you know
it's your newsletter
you'll so piss off